le leem c'est à ce moment de l'explosion
le vidéoclip du rapport américain
milestone 2
tonnes d'or
le lean la saison où le propos zhang
comme on surnomme dans la rue c'est
enfin sirops contre la toux à la codéine
ou un autre pionnier comme hydrocodone
mélangé à une boisson gazeuse
déjà dans les années 60 des bluesmen de
houston ont versé dans leur bière
[Musique]
dans les années 90 la drogue est adoptée
par une partie la communauté rom est
depuis quelques années elle est plus
populaire que jamais gucci mane futur
léopold certains des plus grands noms de
la scène rap en parle dans leurs
morceaux
cause
[Musique]
bieber a d'abord été dépendant dans un
documentaire diffusé en 2020
et on en voit partout sur les réseaux
sociaux
les lignes devenue tellement populaire
que des individus en fabrique
aujourd'hui des versions contrefaites
c'est loin d'être un produit
pharmaceutique notre façon dans une
caisse en plastique d'un voyage de
retour
de la formule de la chute
mais dans la rue le vrai line est une
denrée rare qui se vend à prix d'or
contacté sur instagram deux revendeurs
devraient sirops contre la toux à la
codéine ont accepté de me rencontrer
leurs bouteilles proviennent directement
de pharmacie grâce à les intermédiaires
qui ont accès à des prescriptions ou de
l'étranger de pays où la loi est plus
laxistes
sur sa table pour convaincre les
quelques milliers de dollars de ce héros
un petit peu on dit me mo pourquoi ça
vaut si cher que ça je veux c'est du
sirop contre la toux je me bagarre de la
codéine dedans
mais c'est plus cher que les meilleurs
champagnes demande faisait assez n'est
ce pas ce que tout reste aussi difficile
d'accès au si c'est une déduction pour
cela revoir au dessus l'impression qu'il
ya une recrudescence ou un gain
d'intérêt comme sont sur le court cette
drague lancement c'est sur son mac os
durable justement vu que c'est exclusif
et que c'est une bande difficiles
d'accès comme celle ci est cher et on
peut on faire l'apologie ou organes en
2002 lors en verre ou 250 de leur côté
les pharmacies et des restrictions
d'accès tout ça ça augmente repris avec
de plus en plus tu vois qu'il faut
qu'ils tombent dans la rue de plus en
plus comment savoir des contrefaçons
hills a fait en sorte que le vrai
commence à coûter plus cher
j'ai rencontré un de ses producteurs de
faux sirop à la codéine et je vais
visiter ce que certains appelleraient un
laboratoire clandestin dans son garage
facteurs peuvent expliquer ce que tu
fais ce soir ici en fait
on charbonneau ont fait la paix avec un
petit peu de ce
métal à quoi mais nous savons
qu est-ce qui a fait un saut dans le
fossé la prometteuse en cours avec tout
ce qui marque aussi
je dois m ce sont des socios
laïque sommeil ça goûte impossible qu'on
voit
bien que c'est pas exactement
qualité femmes à 5 ans donc on
s'arrangeait pas son nom
trouve ça ou la codéine que tu mets dans
ces produits c'est une autre étape
normalement six camps contre le pauvre
dont quelqu'un ces prescriptions pour un
mal quoi que ce soit ce sera plus
lorsqu'il fait soudain très bonne
journée pas de pouls des nains oh my pet
on met des limites connues
n'importe quoi qu'elle peut trouver qui
fâche les ventes du laboratoire onu
produits shdm et son époux riat on a
pour seul taupe et ont fait du bon lui
la consommation récréative de codéine et
dangereuse pris en trop grande quantité
elle peut poser des dépressions
respiratoires
surtout lorsque mélangé avec d'autres
drogues ou de l'alcool
au québec kevin denis un jeune lavallois
de 26 ans est mort d'une surdose en 2020
il a subi le même sort que dj school le
producteur de rap texan qui a popularisé
line décédé en 2000
[Musique]
la popularité du ligne ici antique au
bord de l'eau et de l'autre mais
non intervenants jeunesse à chambly fait
les vaillancourt s'est frotté à ce monde
pendant des années avant d'opter pour la
sobriété c'est quand tu consommes studio
du faune c'est une chose que tu
consommes parce que tu as le mal de
vivre que sa voix premier n'était pas
capable de gérer des émotions pour avoir
en parler des programmes de demander de
l'aide on n'est pas la glace tout en a
déjà fait du lean
jamieson
je
n'exclus rien on semble acquise à la
cocaïne mais j'essaie pas mal tous les
droits qui existent fidh le l'insee
j'ai dit à tous c'est cool c'est
ce qu'a t on dans tes
brise-vitres l'accès
serait quelque chose de social
c'est la voie qui les jeunes populaires
en raison de la popularité du lean la
gendarmerie royale du canada a ajouté la
codéine à son tableau de sensibilisation
aux drogues qui notamment distribué dans
les écoles secondaires et je dois dire
que j'en entends parler de plus en plus
on est dans la même famille que les
moyennes entre autres que le fentanyl
donc est ce que c'est possible d'en
prendre trop et de faire un arrêt
cardio-respiratoire tout à fait de se
retrouver dans comment tout à fait et
que ça peut mener jusqu'à un décès c'est
des choses qui sont arrivées tout à fait
ici on ne parle pas de médicaments
disponibles sur les tablettes une
prescription d'un médecin est nécessaire
pour acheter la plupart des sirops à la
codéine les pharmaciens peuvent aussi en
distribuer des versions beaucoup plus
faible en narcotiques à leurs clients
on devrait pas avant ses produits longs
mais comme les patients sont orphelins
il est passé ont pas accès facilement
leur médecin de famille quelquefois il
faut quand même que le pharmacien
surtout avec des solutions sous la main
pour aider des gens qui sont mal pris
donc donc ceci ça c'est des produits qui
sont ces tribus seulement avec une
prescription ou et puis on en voit de
moins en moins là les médecins sont
frileux avec les appuis assez la
dernière année mais quand ils vont en
donner c'est vraiment un coup de crosse
tout puis à ce moment là les quantités
sont quand même assez restreint qui
inquiète est ce qu'on pourrait penser
que le fait que les médecins et les
pharmaciens
le fait qu'ils soient de plus en plus
frileux à prescrire ou à donner ce genre
de produit la messe à pousser le marché
noir à en créer façon contre 7,2 ou
frelatés ainsi sauf que c'est ce qui
s'est produite et aux etats unis quand
alain fentanyl est devenu plus de ces
lourds l'oxycontin est devenu plus
difficile d'accès pour les patients qui
avaient pu dès prescrite en cantonais et
aisément le marché la contrefaçon ces
faits puis dans ton l'indépendance cette
déplace à ce moment là d'un produit à
l'autre
bout
l'amérique roche
alors donc on shore mais c'est pas grave
la codp et non pas 40 de nos pieds est
clairement trop mesurés grand chose ça
peut être dangereux lettre concerne les
cinq mois sur ce coup kg avec modération
comme on dit ça pas mal d'autres vendent
un produit dans ton aucune idée de la
teneur
finalement je suis assez des jeunes qui
ont peut-être bon je sais pas la moitié
là c'est quand même inscrit ce résulat
war exact mais moi j'ai eu dès
maintenant pour ce que j'ai expérimenté
j'ai fait expérimenter avant de le
vendre quoi c'est pas femme à ce texte à
quoi je souffre mais on fait avec ce
qu'on ôte d'ombré un mois dessus de
tempes rasées wajid où coûteux
pour le commander dans le bourg trop de
ton coin qui voit deux
des producteurs achètent achètent sur la
darknet sont pas nécessairement testés
sont là tous entendu qu'il s'agit d'un
petit peu de fin d'année pour
éventuellement créer une surdose
s'apprête arriver
touax au globe on n'est pas l'abri tout
sa faute elle qui rendent le
on joue à la roulette russe est aussi
simple que ça on a une fausse impression
de sécurité parce qu'on a une bouteille
de sirop qui a l'air d'une vraie
bouteille sais pas d'où ça vient c'est
pas qui a fait ça c'est la personne qui
a fait ça
qui mène au fait qu'est ce que toi tu es
100% certain que c'est du vrai lit tout
le plus certifié 100 % directement dans
son petit de la pharmacie vous êtes au
courant roc est un proche du guide
sous courant que sa conduite est
dangereux ce qui me demanderait ce que
je me sens mal de le vendre
ont nécessairement vivant ce sera parce
que les laines certaine le monde
et spécialise la santé les corps
policiers auront beau vouloir contrôler
l'accès aux opioïdes comme siro à la
codéine et dans la rue la demande est
toujours là le marché noir s'adapte un
peu comme le jeu du chat et de la souris
et ça et trafiquants ont très bien
compris